20:17 a world divided with only one  thing that can unite us all no not that  sharks  why is it I was going to be sure yep  we're making America bait again this  could be the last curtain call not just  for America but for the world that's  right this time it's going global  I was oculi about this the bigger  stronger stranger  for another shotgun the ba ba this  summer the phenomenon that swept the  country four times before is now taking  the world by storm literally that is  messed up  it's the next chapter of the franchise  that's been hailed as gloriously idiotic  and absolutely pointless it's I'm sorry  hey oh my god your children Michael well  everyone's replaceable  [Music]  [Music]  sharknado 5 global swarming that's a  huge shark  that's like shark that the scapula  you